[Music]
hey hey dude just give me a second I'm
out of breath is this book ten feet a
little fat I know that's your why you
guys brought it up being fat isn't that
fun anymore like it used to be fun like
John Candy could be in movies when I was
a kid but now the fat people on TV are
getting made fun of like TV makes fat
people look stupid like that if there's
a commercial and there's a fat guy in it
he's the guy that bought the wrong thing
Jimmy understand he's got the broken car
like why doesn't my car work oh that's
right I'm fat afraid all about I've been
thinking about meatballs when I bought
this car why don't I concentrate I'm so
fat there's no fat rights leader that's
the whole problem
there's no Martin Luther Burger King jr.
to come out in fact I'm the only fat guy
my whole apartment building I live in LA
I I've always lived in apartments I've
never had a house you know I've always
had people beneath me and I neither side
of me and above me I have knew upstairs
neighbors that like just moved in birdie
know their whole schedule 6:00 a.m. they
all get together in a living room and
they drop a bowling ball 6:15 they
Riverdance in the kitchen for a while
7:00 a.m. they take the couch and just
move it up the hallway for no reason
let's see how the couch looks in the
bathroom okay doesn't fit same thing
happened yesterday that's weird well
we're trying it tomorrow same time
everybody there's a couple that live
right next to me and their bathroom is
right up against my bedroom so they wake
up at 6:00 a.m. and they argue in their
bathroom they here but they argue this
close to my head but I never hear the
words
[Music]
so I met him in the elevator
I don't just call us for arguing I dated
one girl who would yell at me all day we
go to bed we take a break for eight
hours and then we wake up and she'd yell
at me again sometimes should wait and
will wake me up to yell MA
you ever get woken up to join an
argument that's already in progress and
you're losing and you have no idea what
the topic is yes but get up and pissed
off about something come on you're
losing an argument defend yourself I had
a dream we were doing something screwed
up come on I had a dream you were having
sex with another woman really I was
having the same drink it's a perfect
anyway she's dead now
[Laughter]
I don't like getting woken up I got
woken up at 7 a.m. by guys outside my
window trimming trees just trimming tree
branches at 7 a.m. like exactly at 7
like the minute the clock changed
they started trimming trees which means
they were on the trees at 6:58 alright
guys we're gonna be jerks in two minutes
you know what I want to do was just wait
through that with done trimming and like
follow Malter the houses and wait
outside their bedroom windows and
waiting for them to go to bed just go
[Music]
[Music]
then I wait like 10 minutes go
[Music]
why would you do that 7:00 a.m.
trees are gonna be there at noon you
know they wake up and leave or stop
dodging him guys who have those jobs
they're jerks because they're pissed off
they have those jobs that's their
revenge on us for not having those jobs
like is that the best time to get our
garbage five o'clock in the morning is
that we chose as a society like what
time to get a buddy's garbage 5:00 a.m.
give me the loudest truck you have to I
want to wake up and think there's a
robot taking a poop outside my window
actually pull the muscle in that joke do
you think somewhere in the world is a
Chinese guy who's really ticklish and
his name is Gitchee goo
[Applause]
you